hi I'm Philippa Perry I'm a
psychotherapist and I'm here to chat to
you today about the situation we all
find ourselves in which is new and
strange what are we supposed to think
about it what we supposed to do about it
some people want to know why it's so
weird this isolation thing and I can
give you a little example about that so
my daughter came tapped on the window
waved to me and then walked away again
she did that solo and yet I took it like
a rejection my head nu is a hello but my
body thought it was like we're all
feeling this it's mind body dissonance
it's your head telling you something
your body feeling something else we're
in a new situation it's all completely
weird and it will take some getting used
to
nobody knows how at the moment because
it's a new situation but I've got a
feeling we will get used to it and we
will muddle through and we will find a
way and there's no way of getting it
right you're gonna have feelings about
it
it's okay to have those feelings you
don't have to be happy the whole time
the most important thing at this time
and every time really but we can forget
about it is our relationships and
looking after them I can't see them one
little tip is when you're skyping look
at the lens it's far more intimate when
we look at the camera another thing is
it's strange when we only have the
exchange of words because we're used to
this thing of being with someone in a
sort of body-to-body way and one way we
can stay with and be with people is to
have these Skype machines switched on
while you're watching the same TV
program while you're cooking or
something
it's incredibly intimate really
what if I get so stressed that they take
it out on my kids if you do snap at them
apologize don't think you have to blame
them for you losing your temper go oh
I'm so sorry I shouldn't have snapped at
you then I'm stressed it's not your
fault it's kind of tricky if the kids
are around you and you can't be fully
with them because you've got to work
because if mum and dad are there but
they're not playing with you
even though you've been told it's
because they have to work
you will feel it as rejection as a child
the best thing to do in this situation
is not to say to them look I'll play
with you and I've done my work the best
thing to do is to play with them first
and try and get them on something I call
autopilot so if you're playing with you
know they want you to talk dollies at
the dolls house or make broom broom
noises with the truck they'll eventually
take over from you because you won't be
doing it right but they feel secure that
you're interested in them and you're
engaged with them so they won't need to
keep checking
so you'll gradually be able to retreat
until you're almost on the laptop and
doing those spreadsheets but if you try
and do your spreadsheets first they'll
keep going have you done it yet have you
done it yet have you done it yet just
worry about the quality of time you have
when you're with them because that's the
most important thing it doesn't really
matter if they finish that school
project or not what matters is that you
enjoyed being together more is society
collectively feeling don't think we've
been this United for a long time at
least now we've got a common enemy
instead of fighting each other over
brexit remember brexit we will probably
all make up our own narrative about it
so if you are a healer like a yoga
teacher you'll say the earth is healing
because we've got no pollution at the
moment
from aeroplanes if you're a meditative
sort of personal girl I'm exploring my
inner landscape if you're a pessimist
you'll go the end of the world is nigh
and these are the ways we soothe
ourselves and it's fine we can make up
whatever story helps us get through I
quite like the healing the world one the
world will keep spinning for another few
billion years why is it so hard for
teenagers when you're a teenager you're
all about finding a new tribe and
leaving the family behind you're ready
to separate you're ready to make your
way in the world and you're ready to
start mating as well and you so want to
get on with that you know to us six
months is nothing to them it's like
another lifetime and so they will be
angry and they will be frustrated that
they've had to put the brakes on this
new exploration this new time of life
and we must be sympathetic that you know
theirs is the only generation not going
to pop festivals this year and setting
fire to their tent like they were
looking forward to doing another thing
is if you think about the teenage brain
their emotions are at their peak height
they can feel in color and our feeling
is like black and white in comparison
but their frontal lobes the cerebral
cortex this bit here where you do your
thinking and your reasoning that isn't
completely wired up yet so they've got
all the impulses but but but not the
mechanism to hold those impulses in
check necessarily those are still
developing and we can't fix it for them
we want to we want them to have that
great time we can't fix it but we can be
alongside them if they know we
understand it won't cure it it won't fix
it but it might make it a little bit
better how the hell am I going to
maintain my relationship with my partner
in this intensive lockdown situation
now not only will our relationship with
our child be under stress but maybe
being cooped up with your partner the
whole time or your sister or whoever it
is you normally live with is going to be
tricky too my first problem is that my
husband used to go out about twice a
week on his own and I could catch up
with my cookery programmes that are
record and I used to go out once or
twice a week and he would watch his war
films then but now we have no time for
these separate individual activities
because we do insist on sitting on the
sofa together and not having separate
TVs and I think the best thing to do is
not sweat the small stuff and if you get
told off for stacking the dishwasher
bran just go oh you're so right rather
than make it into a win-lose situation
you can carry on stacking the dishwasher
how you always do it but listen and go
oh it must be hard for you that I stuck
it wrong you know just be nice if you
can be if there is any trouble in any
relationship this will put a magnifying
glass on it and maybe that's a good
thing because then you'd know you've got
an issue you have to sort out after
people have spent Christmas together
divorce rates go up in January so I'm
expecting maybe this enforced period of
isolation will have the same effect
and nothing I can say now will make any
difference how do I deal with the
uncertainty this is also new this
isolation stuff but you might wake up in
the morning and think nots different
something's different
and then remember it's almost like you
wake up from one dream and into another
that doesn't feel real so we feel a bit
weird and a bit odd and a bit ungrounded
which isn't helped by not being in
contact with people that we're normally
in contact with now you might think but
I live on my own and I love living on my
own and it's great the thing is when you
live on your own you're choosing to live
on your own and you go out into the
world you maybe go to an office and then
you come back and be on your own and
there's a rhythm to it and and you can
self-regulate by being on your own and
you love your alone time but if you have
to be alone and it's not a choice
it will feel weird give it time it's
early days you're not supposed to have
this thing worked out by now you will
work it out in your own way like you
always work things out in your own way
it's just that we haven't done it yet
you might think when will this be over
and how can I cope with not knowing what
the future holds you never did know what
the future held
we just kid ourselves the such a thing
of certainty the only thing that is
certain is that everything keeps
changing all the time and the difference
sometimes between sane and insane is
being able to accept change or being
denial about it
here's a time for us all to practice
accepting change
you